foreign
[Applause]
things YouTube channel today I am
attending the Bitcoin 2023 conference in
Miami I don't know anything about
Bitcoin I want to see what the deal is
about Bitcoin so today you are gonna see
me get orange filled and see if I'm
gonna hop on the train like the video on
your way and subscribe to the channel
let's get started what so what's a
bitcoin a Bitcoin is a part of you it's
a part of me it's an agreement on a
fixed set of rules that we can organize
ourselves by so it's just a mathematical
equation running in the back of your
head and it's all about keeping a secret
if you know how to keep a secret you can
you can do Bitcoin I don't get it no you
you will though you will hi what are
your names Brandon Aladdin can you tell
me like what is a Bitcoin it is anti-us
dollar your US dollar is depreciating
Bitcoin is appreciating so it's digital
scarcity what is a digital skit I don't
understand that you know what makes
money valuable at the end of the day is
it's got to be a story value you know
and our our dollar is fiat currency
because it has a medium exchange it's
portable durable but it's not a store of
value money has to be a story value so
we continually have this lie people are
saving these dollars they think are an
asset but it's actually a liability
that's why they get poorer over time and
that was the digital version of gold but
a thousand times better because it moves
over time and space unlike gold that
can't move what do you mean it moves
over time the value of it you have to be
able to when you're conducting Commerce
and buying something you have to be able
to move it over time and space and if
you're buying something that's in
Thailand it has to be able to move over
space instantaneously at speed of
Commerce gold can't do that so that you
inevitably have these claim checks on
them dollars or digital representations
of that like what's Bitcoin different
from money yeah I wouldn't I would say
that is way better than money every
other type of money requires some trust
in some institution or that that people
aren't printing more of it which they
are obviously obviously and with Bitcoin
that doesn't work can print more of it
no one can
I can't print they can't make like code
more Bitcoins or anything no absolutely
not that's the whole point of it that it
doesn't change over time what's your
book called the famous book is called
Everything divided by 21 million once
you get into Bitcoin it so deep and the
rabbit hole goes so incredibly deep into
so many directions that it's easy to get
lost so we put that all in this pack
simplified and made it fun this is rare
this says taxation is theft taxes are
mandatory contributions often
unauthorized that a government agency
whether local Regional or federal
imposes on people or businesses taxation
is the process through which a
government or other organizations
demands that individuals and businesses
pay an involuntary fee it differs from
the other types of payment in the market
because it doesn't require Mutual
consent it isn't a direct result of any
goods or services that have been
provided governments Force taxation upon
citizens with the threat of course so I
actually have a question what about like
the roads roads
that we're doing we don't need Road all
right guys I've been told this is what
you're supposed to read this is like the
Bible of Bitcoin I'm not a bitcoiner I
don't really know what we're we're doing
but this is the Bitcoin standard all
right then you go to the the Fiat Fiat
standard this is the debt slavery
alternative to human civilizations they
love when I cover this topic
and then principles of economics and
like the firemen and the police officers
like don't they have to take taxes for
that if I have a money printer and I can
print unlimited amounts of money at the
push of a button then why would I need
your measly a couple thousand bucks a
year I can literally push a button and
print trillions of dollars in a matter
of a second those roads can easily be
printed with that money printer so if
that's where the money has to come from
is somewhere well then all of the
inflation that comes from that trillion
dollar print that they send that money
all over the world and pack all of these
politicians with that trillion how about
not packing the politicians with those
trillions how about taking care of the
roads so that we can afford to pay for
good schools for our children good
education all of the other things that
we work our butts off for how does
Bitcoin change the culture Bitcoin
changes the culture because it levels
the playing field right once we're all
in a Bitcoin in standard we all have the
same opportunity to acquire hold save
see our money appreciate there's
transparency in the money supply that
means that nobody can print more Bitcoin
there's only ever going to be 21 million
and then it's capped everyone has the
same opportunity to mine Bitcoin it
requires resources in order to mine
Bitcoin which again levels the playing
field if this video gets a million views
can I get a card if this video gets a
million views she gets a card why does
everyone say Bitcoin
understand why does
not like Bitcoin institutions don't like
it because it takes their you know the
two percent or three percent all the
finance charges everything that takes
their grift away and with Bitcoin we
don't need the money printer and that
money printer is what feeds their Yachts
who would be at the top of the
problematic pyramid the wef go to their
website look it up in their slogan you
will own nothing and be happy
so what is this what is here if you look
at the back of your dollar bill you got
the pyramid right with the All-Seeing
Eye yeah okay so now I built this
concept of the Bitcoin pyramid with the
Bitcoin being on top over the foundation
of dead currencies Fiat currencies okay
and that's what all these are right here
and then basically just kind of
describes what Bitcoin is it's
borderless I can spend it back and forth
just you and me I don't need a bank and
then it actually is a store of value and
Satoshi Nakamoto is the guy supposedly
that invented the protocol for Bitcoin
blockchain is the protocol where you can
actually do transactions that are
verified by miners so if you've walked
around and seen all these miners that
have all these equipment and stuff they
can actually verify transactions I don't
understand yeah because I don't
understand like if it's digital like
what are you my like okay so so it's
like this guy made this math equation I
think that was for the Bitcoin
and that was the Satoshi guy so he made
that and I understand the concept like
there's a set amount so that's good and
there's no and everybody's involved so
like we don't have to rely on the
government right I understand that's
good and you can it's borderless so you
could do it from anywhere unlike gold I
understand that's good I don't
understand like how how are if he
created 21 million Bitcoin how are they
mining for Bitcoin like that's what I
don't understand well it's it's it's to
verify a transaction okay so if I send
you one Bitcoin a miner will come in and
say okay I have the Bitcoin to give to
you so uh we're gonna verify that
transaction because we know that I have
the Bitcoin and you I say who I am and
you say who you are so verifying that
transaction they get paid in Bitcoin if
the US was still on the gold standard
would we need Bitcoin the problem with
gold is what we were talking about
earlier now we're coming full circle so
gold can't move across space meaning if
you buy something in Thailand like we
were saying earlier you can't have vinyl
settlement meaning they don't actually
have money they just have a claim check
or like a digit in a computer somewhere
saying hey you bought this but that
value the actual gold didn't move it's
still in a vault somewhere and the
problem is governments or entities
commercial Banks they go put out way
more ious into the system than they
actually have gold then you have Bank
runs because then all these ious are out
there people come back to reclaim what
they think they have in a vault gold but
then they realize oh we gave it a
million claim checks a million notes or
ious and there's only a hundred thousand
in Gold there so now 900 000 of that is
completely invisible gone and those
people lose out whoever goes first gets
theirs whoever comes last they're
they're screwed so you still need that
because gold has always been centralized
it always goes into Banking and goes
into governments so you have to have
Bitcoin because gold has been the best
thing we've had for 5 000 years but it
doesn't fit the bill because of that
because it can't move across space
easily like Bitcoin can I still don't
really understand what a Bitcoin is I'm
kind of the i o user confusing me
bitcoin's energy
Satoshi don't know so Satoshi is
anonymous and we have no idea who
Satoshi is and that's the most beautiful
part maybe it's me I'll take credit so
if you send me one Bitcoin and the miner
wants to like verify it how did they get
paid they get paid by verifying the
block and what's up happening through
the protocol and the math as you call it
it is generated through a lot of math
they get paid at the end of that
transaction in Bitcoin and then they can
take that Bitcoin and put it on the
market and sell it so will it ever be a
point where we don't need the miners
anymore uh 2140 there will be no more
Bitcoin to mine so the miners they will
only make money off of transaction fees
when I send you Bitcoin you send me
Bitcoin oh so and so when that happens
how many what percent will they get of
the Bitcoin every time you you send a
Bitcoin when you send a Bitcoin you have
to pay a network fee
and that's the only fee to get paid oh
and that's how everyone's that's how it
keeps it more secure because you're not
relying on the government and then the
government also doesn't see what you're
doing with your money all right guys
this is a very high IQ type of
conversation I really can't always keep
up sometimes I'm starting to get it I'm
starting to get it but they lose me a
bit they lose me a bit so so far this is
what I understand right Bitcoin is
different because
it's got this code that everyone can be
a part of so therefore we're not just
printing money anymore then the second
part is the Federal Reserve is bad it's
a private institution and three there's
Bitcoin miners all around the world so
they're all involved and it was created
by a guy we don't know yeah it could be
it could be me you know what I mean
maybe I'm just undercover
that there should be in like your
perfect world there would still be some
taxation for like the the police
officers the firemen roads none how
would you pay for it then we would pay
for that ourselves but we would also
have control over what they were doing
so that they couldn't make the rules and
smash us down yeah the construction
takes forever I don't know who's in
charge of all the you you know you're
fired
yes yes so tell me what what do you do
what's your role here so my role at BTC
Inc which runs the conference and
Bitcoin magazine is head of community so
um I basically coordinate our efforts
with local Bitcoin meetups and anything
that happens uh you know in in real life
relationships among bitcoiners basically
why are you guys so passionate about
this it's the the Bitcoin Community is
like crazy we have this opportunity to
really transform the world when you look
around it's like what are the solutions
who's fixing inflation who's fixing
corruption who's fixing all of the
things that uh plague our societies and
have been playing our societies for you
know 100 100 years 100 plus years uh as
the money continues to die and so
Bitcoin is one of those really unique
things that offers people that kind of
Hope where if we can actually transition
to a sound money then maybe we can start
fixing all of the things that are broken
with the world world and with Society
with relationships why is Bitcoin going
to change the world like what it seems
like it's okay it's an internet currency
how does that change society and culture
you first have to understand what money
is and how it's broken in order to go
about figuring out what the solutions
are right and so right now what we have
is a currency that is controlled by a
small group of people they can print at
will they can create more money and that
may that means that I'm sorry to cut you
that's politicians right politicians
Central Bankers mostly like the FED
anytime you hear about we need to raise
the debt limit or we need to but that's
like interest rates interest rates all
of it all the stuff that we actually
like don't really fully understand they
just kind of it's all smoke and mirrors
and people making these decisions that
are kind of arbitrary what it's done is
uh is it's created Dynamics among people
who are participating in the economy
that are unjust they're not really fair
because if someone has an advantage
where they're closer to the money
printer whether that's large
corporations or or Banks or whatever
they have an unfair advantage against
the little guy who's you know working a
a wage job we are in this debt based
economy right now where where borrowing
money has kind of become necessary in a
lot of ways and saving has become
unpractical because people are not
incentivized to save money because if
you save money right now it's going to
be worth less in a year in five years
and 10 years right so actually people
are incentivized to spend money as
quickly as they can right now and that's
a that's a fundamentally broken part of
our economy right it used to be even
when we were younger you know 20 30 40
years ago people were incentivized to
save money and that was like a habit and
that was considered a good habit now
it's kind of like well if I save it's
I'm putting out the same amount of
energy to work compared to the little
guy because if he saves the money and
his only choice before like Bitcoin is
to use dollars and so if he saves
dollars to start a business it's unfair
because they're taking the money like
before his eyes by printing more of it
so it's not as valuable and that's why
screws yes so that's why it screws the
little guy because he can't even do what
he's supposed to do like if he makes
let's say 15 an hour you could still
save in like a year or whatever 20
whatever whatever number you want to say
is like low low paying you could still
save and start a business like even if
your only skill is making sandwiches you
could save and open a sandwich business
but because of the money they can't do
that is what you're saying it's like
this treadmill of like you're trying to
you're trying to keep up you're trying
to save but you're not getting uh your
wages aren't keeping up with inflation
so what are like because part of my head
goes well we have the highest standard
of living than ever before
like my dad and his generation they
didn't have like air conditioning they
didn't have like I think they register
people in a low income even if they have
like TVs you know a lot of like dis you
know discretionary spending I guess so
how do you balance the the little guys
getting screwed over but we also have
the highest standard of living as ever
than ever before I think it's kind of
it's a subjective thing right there are
certainly things that have gotten better
right air conditioning and uh having
toilets that flush uh those are nice
things to have but then you look at
things like you know technology uh and
the way that it now mediates Human
Relationships I think it's questionable
whether or not that's actually better
for humans or not um there are things
that are positive about technology
Twitter and you know social media and
there are things that are obviously
deteriorating social dynamics you know
doordash for instance or Uber Uber is
very convenient but Uber drivers make
less than cab drivers used to right so
there's all these things where it's like
what are we also undoing even though the
standard of living is improve but there
are things that are actually getting
worse the the better that technology
gets it's kind of ironic so guys this is
my cousin Jonathan say hello hello world
why why did you want me to become a
bitcoiner uh I think it's Gonna Save the
World it's gonna piss off all the
feminists which is fine I love doing
that and the reason for that though is
because nothing can be fake and so
Bitcoin is going to make everything have
actual value because you can't just be
usurped by any government doesn't matter
whose government it is all of our
problems stem back from money if you
corrupt the money you corrupt the
culture uh who controls the money the
Federal Reserve yes and who controls the
food uh companies that make food and who
are they control by I I guess the owners
of the companies the FDA Department of
Agriculture oh that's true so if you
have an FDA who is your Federal
Department of Agriculture ruled by the F
uh I'm blanking right now the Federal
Reserve which by the way is not actually
a federal entity It Is by name only
um FDIC is also not actually Insurance
FDIC is a fun way of saying taxes on
everyone so you think that the money
ruins Society I I think it was women
voting I think they're intertwined I
think if you go far enough back you
realize cheap money made it easy for men
to be week created a gap or a void that
women had to step into and so weak men
created a need for women to be stronger
quote unquote and then ultimately just
tipped the scale of what it should
actually be how did the money make weak
Matt if someone controls how you're
measuring the value of your work like
money is a store of value okay so at the
end of the day if I pay you pearl one
dollar and you have a decision to make
do I put that money in the bank and save
it for future goods and services or do I
spend it instantaneously on like a food
like a hamburger or a cheeseburger looks
like that if somebody can debase that
money all they have to do is turn on a
money printer so they didn't have to do
any work they can just change the value
of your dollar if two dollars get into
the economy your dollar is not worth one
anymore it's worth 50 cents and so the
problem is the government made people
weaker because they made them believe
certain things that weren't true is you
felt like you had a lot of money but you
really didn't because at the end of the
day like right now a house is worth five
hundred thousand dollars if you're
living the coast well you could have
bought the same house 50 years ago for
fifty thousand dollars right and the
value of that house actually didn't go
up the value of the money paying for the
house went down so at the end of the day
if you if you worked your entire life if
you worked 50 years and you worked 50
years because you thought 75 000 was a
good salary and then you turn around and
your kids are making 150 000 for the
same job that you did you're demoralized
what is mine Bitcoin so mining Bitcoin
uh means that you're you're using
basically electricity you plug in an
Asic which is a Bitcoin miner and uh
it's a Bitcoin miner a a person or is
that a machine yeah it's kind of hard to
explain but it's a machine that you plug
in and basically the more power that you
use to mine Bitcoin the more opportunity
you have to actually compete in the
mining market so it's kind of like think
about when you mine gold in order to
mine gold you have to have a lot of
resources in order to hire an excavator
to go out hire people and it costs money
in order to extract it from the earth
Bitcoin mining is similar in that way
like you can't it's not free to mine
Bitcoin you have to you have to invest
in order to do it but anyone can do it
right so it's a even playing field well
I thought it was them doing math I
thought it was like I thought it was
some girl like sitting on her computer
doing some math but I'm getting so it's
not it's not it's literally you plug in
a machine and it just goes it just
starts like to spin up and it just like
it's
and then the most it's called hash power
the person who has the most hash power
has the highest percentage chance of
finding the next block and whoever finds
the next block whichever minor whichever
machine finds the next block gets the
block reward which right now is about
6.25 Bitcoin you know as you look around
Society right now we're very divided
people don't people are at each other's
throats over everything bitcoiners have
found this common ground of what they
want to see in the world
um and I think that's that's that's
really where it starts like when I get
together like when you get together at a
conference like this and you're just
having conversations with bitcoiners you
can actually have real conversations
about real issues that are happening
without worrying about people like
canceling you or judging you or whatever
and not even necessarily because
everybody agrees on everything that's
not the case at all it's just that
everybody agrees that everybody should
be free to uh interact and transact and
live and participate in an economy in a
way that is just and is not corrupted
and is not mitigated by the government
or by Regulators or whatever else all
right guys I'm finishing up day one and
I've learned a couple lessons today so
essentially the government is robbing us
because it's a small group of people
printing all the money and therefore
even when we make money we have no
incentive to save and really build
Financial Freedom and we're depending on
the government which apparently the
people printing the money it's like a
private institution and the politicians
are shareholders we think and so they're
not really incentivized to make the best
policies for the people now Bitcoin
apparently is different because there's
a set number of Bitcoin everyone can see
it
um and it's very transparent and I don't
really understand how the miners work
but basically anyone can become a minor
verify payments make sure it's real
we're being robbed in front of our eyes
okay I'm kind of confused I'm a bit
confused that the math equation I don't
really understand the math I'm confused
about how you mine a Bitcoin
I'm confused on how if the internet went
off tomorrow how Bitcoin would continue
to go
um I'm a bit confused apparently Bitcoin
like bad money has ruined families
Society uh the food I don't really fully
understand that but I do see the value
in having a currency that has a set
number I think that's important I do see
the value of having a currency that the
government has no part of so that I
understand but the other parts I'm a bit
lost but thank you guys um tune in
tomorrow you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
come back here so we'll see what I
learned tomorrow